[Musique]
vous avez une belle et longue carrière
après les collations le théâtre ça a
vraiment décollé pour voir 1968 avec le
ch'ti choo mettant en vedette louise
forestier robert charlebois yvon
deschamps et vous même
quels souvenirs gardez-vous de cette
époque magique
alors nous on était désobéissants on
n'avait pas envie de vieillir en rond
c'est inventer quelque chose qui nous
permettait de faire à peu près ce qu'on
voulait avec beaucoup d'inconscience
quelque chose qui n'aurait pas été
acceptée maintenant parce que maintenant
tout est formaté penser ce qu'on veut
le studio n'a pas pu voir le jour en
2001 non c'est une idée de fou sas a pu
voir le jour parce qu'ils vont faisait
partie de l'équipe du quat'sous qui
avait un trou dans la programmation 200
des 300 pages de votre nouvelle
biographie part de votre relation avec
robert charlebois est ce que ça vous a
permis d'accomplir de grandes choses de
grandes chansons de grandes mises en
scène ou si cette relation là
enseignants ont su comment ces lieux
très haut et ça a été extraordinaire c
c'est pour ça que ça a été aussi
douloureux comme ça ne plus fonctionner
parce que j'étais gâté j'étais aux
premières loges à 20 euros par là qui je
mentais méchants sont très forts et très
loin j'avais quelqu'un qui
s'épanouissait sur cinq avec lequel
j'avais étudié à l'école nationale dont
je connaissais c'est enfin sans
prétention ses forces et ses faiblesses
je pourrais conseiller ou lui dire ça
quand il fait soleil aussi car en
continu dans ce vent glacé
je me fous pas mal
je lui dis
move parmi vos plus belles chansons
interprétées par robert charlebois
madame bertram sp psy deux femmes en or
ordinaire au renard c'est ma préférée
comment avez-vous eu l'idée d'écrire eu
de chance je sais crise au petit
notamment parce que moi j'ai toujours un
petit cahier avec moi j'écris ça dans
mon cahier d'écolière puis robert
faisais de la musique moi j'ai plutôt
que lui jouait du piano jeu mais ça
manque
et un jour il trouve ya trouvé ce jour
là il ya trouvé ça sur la table de
cuisine quelque chose comme ça puis sané
s'en est emparé puissant musique et le
lendemain matin me durand g funk
tournent sur eux sur tes paroles disent
quelle parole et c'est tout le temps
comme les réflexions un journal pour
pour vrai c'était ordinaire pour l'album
préféré dans la barre charlebois c'est
fou man show et à l'intérieur il ya
magnifique livret vous similaire la
chanson le mur de son mais il ya un
livret où on voit robert charlebois le
pape du showbiz et au dessus de pape qui
ont voix chaude et si on voit m'offre
plus élevé parce que je sais ça c'est ma
synthétique qui plane c'est quoi l'idée
le concept c'est pas mon idée c'est pour
moi qui ai fait la pochette mais y
arrivait beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
cette époque là c'était foisonnant
c'était la plus belle et port pour être
jamais fortunés
c'est pour ça que je permis que carmel
écrire ma biographie après 15 ans
d'insistance jeu non non non tu me faire
mourir parce que j'ai travaillé avec
gilou j'ai fait des ateliers d'écriture
pendant sept pour apprivoiser l'humain
je tourne l'homo jardin et il m'a dit
quand on été gâté par la vie qu'on a eu
la chance de rencontrer des gens
intéressants qu'ils ont appris des
choses tu as un devoir de transmission
il faut pas être égoïste va pas attendre
là aussi elles m'ont enfin peu importe
est tous avec toi
il faut que tu partages j'avais jamais
pensé à ça avant moi c'est toujours mon
intimité à vie privée etc
et c'est pour ça que j'ai accepté de
faire une bille ou pour raconter et
partager ces petites choses pour changer
l'angle je me prends pas pour un
japonais seulement dès lors je sais mais
j'ai fait ma petite part j'ai essayé de
le faire honnêtement avec tous tout mon
coeur tout ce que j'avais ce que c'était
ma passion je ne pouvais pas avoir une
peine d'amour une peine de métier en
même temps au moins j'ai pas une tonne
2006 après votre rupture amoureuse avec
robert charlebois 1976 avait entamé une
deuxième partie votre carrière beaucoup
de mises en scène entre autres en 1984
pour le spectacle my girod zh le diane
dufresne
gray
je suis contente de rencontrer parce que
je croise plusieurs artistes dans le
cadre de ces entrevues lot et vous êtes
vraiment reconnu au mieux pour mettre
les musiciens musiciennes en confiance
comment faites-vous parce que je
prendrais bien un ou deux montres je
sais pas un jour je travaillais aux
gémeaux avec quelqu'un qui m'aime ai pas
beaucoup et c'est une femme père m'a dit
c'est drôle là je te connaissais pas
mais tu es tellement sécurisant tu me
rassures tellement j'ai même pas eu le
trac je l'avais moi mais ça paraissait
pas mais je sais moi qui avais mal au
vent j'avais mal au ventre avec un
sourire merci beaucoup
[Musique]